enormous
container ship got stuck in the suez
canal
blocking one of the world's most vital
shipping routes okay
a massive cargo ship just to kind of put
in perspective how big this thing is
bigger than the eiffel tower bigger than
the statue of liberty
bigger than the empire empire state
building that's how big this thing is
quarter mile long container that is
ridiculous how big this thing is
so i just business insider for every
hour it's
estimated that it's costing 400 million
per
hour per hour's cost on 400 million
dollars so if you're wondering how
uh wondering how a ship that weighs 220
000 tons
and is the size of an empire state
building ended up sideways canal
officials say high winds from a
sandstorm restricted visibility around
the time
the ship got stuck the location on the
ground it couldn't have been worse the
source canal is vital but narrow
link in many global supply chains and
delays there reverberate
around the world around 10 percent of
worldwide shipping traffic flows through
its narrow waters
including roughly five percent of global
traded
crude oil no one is shocked this
happened the suez canal is only
300 feet wide shipping companies uh
usually factor in extra days to their
schedules to account for any unexpected
delays but if it ever
if the ever given club clogs the canal
for longer than that
prices of stranded cargo from crude oil
to consumer good
could be affected tom what do you think
about this
i think we've got an outdated canal
there you know
that nobody wants to pay to make any
bigger and i
i think it's just really really
unfortunate you know there's nothing
controversial i see about this other
than
man this is this canal was built when
you know
and it's never been significantly so
okay so but there's there is a comment
there if that's what you're saying what
you're saying is the world ought to come
together put a budget to fix the canal
if the world can come together and put a
budget to fix the canal that doesn't
become a one person
whoever participates and benefits from
it why don't we reinvest in it is that
kind of what you're saying
yeah you know you take a look at the
panama canal and the suez canal just
take a map
of the globe and say you need those two
you need those two points to get
stuff shipped from here to here i think
there would be an issue with that though
because there's a toll they pay
for going through the so at that point
i'd say if i'm a captain
just we're paying you to go through this
we're paying you to use this road
why don't you fix it that's your problem
it's the toll roads in new england suck
they're all full of potholes all those
tolls just go to the state
to your point it should be used for
maintenance and improvement but
we have a lot of examples on toll roads
around the world that don't
three to five million uh barrels of oil
per day are held back
so that's gonna spike up gas prices uh
yeah
carrying jet fuel and gasoline gasoline
oil
is a gasoline here here's a total map
jack all the ships on the ocean wow
there's is
i think the white i think it's uh they
were saying is like 300
feet wide at one point you got to be
kidding me yeah
yep so it's very tiny oh my gosh
yeah and they all have to stage they
stage their are you kidding me that
little
change yep
wait right there
yeah that little thing right here
are they are they able to fix it or not
yet are they making progress
stuck and the thing is the way the boat
is built
it has like a bow on the front that is
good for weather but that one has
literally dug into the ground so they
need to
like dig in they got to dredge in there
talking about the other part is they got
to start
unloading containers somehow on other
ships so that it'll
become lighter it floats out and they
can readjust it
you're going to unload it this will be
interesting get some cranes out there
ship the ship exactly so this so they're
saying that this can take
days if not weeks to get rid of it which
obviously is going to clog a whole lot
of global trade
and there's talks that they'll be
similar to you know how with the
pandemic
outages in the supply chains because
the only option would be for companies
to send their boats
around uh
horn of africa come up which is
quite the detour and quite the detour i
mean that's just that's ridiculous
and it's heavy weather down there too
there's heavy weather at cape horn it's
like saying there's no panama canal same
thing in the city
take a look at the gulf of mexico see
all those red carpets physically
go physically to what it looks like i'm
sorry go ahead tom you were saying no i
said
we'll go back to that a second let's go
take a look at the there's this
amazing picture of the stuck ship with
this little tiny looks like a lego crane
sitting next to it
digging in the sand look how sideways it
is there it is there you see that so as
canal dredging firm
take a look at that kai uh right nope
right next to it on the right down right
there look at that that's an enormous
tractor look at this
they're digging this out order of a mile
ship yeah and it looks like a little
lego doesn't it just like
down there this is not the question is
how often does this happen
how often does this sandstorms happen
all the time first time
but uh for that to be ground that way
what do they call it
who gets held accountable for something
like this who's accountable for
something like this this is a pretty big
screw-up the world is
i mean the economy is affected by it
first certain industries are affected by
it
who's held accountable for this well
outside of the captain
uh you got to look at the the shipping
company the shipping company you got to
look at the uh the port
the canal controls so
uh this morning brew actually had a good
good comment regarding the
the the trip it's like driving from new
york to philadelphia
via calgary via calgary
yes and it is it adds 6 000 miles
and 300 000 in fuel costs to the journey
of going around versus through wow
so things uh this is a probably possibly
a justification
for again gas prices go up fuel prices
go up other things that the suez canal
ships to other manufacturers for goods
and services that go up
were you looking at the suez canal stuff
or yeah so
basically you've got two choices um
choice number one is you reroute things
choice number two
freaking world comes together and
figures out how to offload some of this
stuff make it
lighter and then you need that's a giant
tractor there you need
[Music]
it's just like you need like 10 of those
this
this ship is the size of a country so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you